scientists at MIT have created a
synthetic material that mimics the
texture and color shifting skin of an
octopus and a new type of edible fungus
has been discovered growing inside of
salami and it's fittingly been named
Penicillium salami Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow a new device allows
you to hear with your tongue
researchers at Colorado State University
are developing the technology which uses
a Bluetooth enabled earpiece to detect
sound and then send the electrical
impulses to a retainer that wearers
press against their tongue to hear
they're currently mapping the nerves on
the tongue and they say it could take
two to three months of wearing the
device to teach your brain to interpret
the signals on your tongue as words or
sounds eventually those with substantial
hearing loss could use this as a
significantly simpler and less expensive
alternative to cochlear implants
researchers at Harvard University have
developed an organic nonmetal flow
battery that is chemically similar to
rhubarb the battery is 97% cheaper to
make the nose made with metal and it's
environmentally friendly a few models
already exist and the technology could
be used to take greater advantage of
intermittent energy sources like wind or
the Sun an engineer in London has
created functioning synthetic leaves
they're created by extracting
chloroplasts from plants and binding
them together with silk fibers these
synthetic leaves engage in
photosynthesis turning co2 into oxygen
and could be used to clean city air or
create oxygen in spaceships or space
colonies $0.06 has developed a motion
tracking platform built specifically for
virtual reality instead of using only a
camera to track a user's motion the stem
system has a base station that sends out
electromagnetic waves which are then
picked up by sensors on the head in the
controller's and on the legs it allows
for a wider range of motion by the user
as well as greater accuracy so it'll be
easier than ever to be a Jedi or go
virtual shoe shopping wetland works is
hoping to implement floating toilets
made with plants there are a number of
floating villages in Cambodia where
traditional plumbing is impossible
thereby increasing the risk of
contracting deadly diseases these
toilets use pods filled with plants like
hyacinths to reduce harmful bacteria in
the wastes by 99.9 percent and the hope
is to implement them in other countries
where villages exist on or near water
the Bloodhound is a rocket car aiming to
break the land speed record this year it
has a jet engine and a hybrid rocket
motor it hopes to achieve speeds higher
than 763 miles per hour and it's
outfitted with 500 sensors and a number
of cameras that transmit data in real
time to help teach children about
engineering and aerodynamics termites
help prevent the spread of desert into
dry lands a recent study from Princeton
reveals that termite mounds are
excellent at storing minerals and
moisture and as a result help plant life
flourish dry lands that had termites
were less likely to turn into desert and
needed less rainfall to sustain their
ecosystems this study suggests that
other burrowing animals might have
similar impacts on dry lands and this
could change the way we look at micro
eco systems story sky is a project by a
Dutch startup to power 300 LEDs using
plants it works by harvesting discarded
protons and electrons from the bacteria
near the plants roots so all you need to
generate electricity is water co2 and
sunlight the project marks Plante's
first commercial installation and you
can now buy plant powered cell phone
charging stations Wi-Fi hotspots and
rooftop electricity modules from their
website finally students at MIT are
experimenting with ice based
architecture by freezing thin cloth with
layers of water they're able to create
winter shelters that utilize
gravitational geometry to remain upright
but those shapes still stood right by
themselves so it was very nice to see
that the frozen fabrics is very strong
even for long funicular
shelter I'm gonna leave you with a tiny
zipper robot and as always thanks for
watching